nothing is impossible impossible is just
a word none of this was possible ask the
impossible the impossible can happen
hello believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn how to do the impossible and as
always if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
if you're leaving a comment within the
first few hours of this video going live
you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes that we have good luck
[Music]
as a child my parents always told me you
could be whatever you want to be you
could do whatever you want to do and you
know that that office that position that
the highest office on the face of the
earth it was something I heard my
parents saying it but I didn't totally
believe it yet I went out in the world
and I carried myself and I held my head
high and I stood there and I look people
in their eyes and I talk to people as if
I was deserving of everything that this
planet has to offer
so I just I really want to say to two
children out there and to two people who
are watching Confucius said one time he
who says he can and he who says he can't
are both usually right so I want to
stand here before you and as I hold this
award I want to give love to my wife and
I want you to keep in your heart just
know that you can know that you do
nothing absolutely nothing is impossible
you can begin again you can believe God
again you can trust again you can be
successful you can overcome your
addictions you can ill you can feel
alive
again this is when you realize that
those things are possible you are
getting a breakthrough so I want to
encourage you right now don't give in
go for it don't give up don't throw in
the towel and even if your back is up
against the wall even if you are on the
ropes and you are receiving a rope but
don't financially listen you got to
fight back you don't get in life what
you want you get what you fight for and
when you decide that my future my health
my marriage my freedom my happiness my
joy my peace my children is worth
fighting for
you are securing your breakthrough just
to go after it I mean the thing about
being an entrepreneur is this it's just
all to you you know a lot of people like
to make excuses I don't have connections
I don't have money I don't have this but
you know if you find something that you
like to do or love to do be great at it
and see if you can turn it into a
business and worst case you're gonna
have fun doing what it is you love to do
in best case you can turn it into a
business i i'm just dumping on excuses i
just think if you really eat
everybody had that opportunity to go for
it they just kind of do it here's maybe
the greatest thing a teen or anyone in
this room and who's watching on the
television at home can learn from the
champ these are words to remember when
anyone tries to tell you to give up tell
you to give in because whatever you're
trying to do is impossible the champ
says this impossible is just a word
thrown around by a small men who find it
easier to live in the world they've been
given than to explore the power they
have to change it impossible is not a
fact it's an opinion impossible this
potential impossible is temporary
impossible is nothing greatest ever
so as a relatively new dad and a former
team I'm here to say you will make
mistakes
along the way you will fall down I have
many times even I'll lead it but what we
do after that fall is how we make
history
because impossible is nothing I don't
really need the money like I don't need
the money anymore I made dream money
from from video games like stuff that I
did things I would never imagined you
know when people say like is this what
you dreamt I didn't dream any of this
none of this was possible or even
considered a reality when I was a kid
you know when I started skating like the
best you could hope for was your picture
in a magazine maybe a pro board maybe
and free gear that's it and then once
you reach an age of responsibility and
this is I'm talking about when I was
like 12 once you reach an age of
responsibility say 18 your career is
over because you're not you can't make
money doing it you can't do it into your
belt life I'm a believer bro I'm like I
see things and I want to make them real
no matter how how hard it takes no
matter what obstacles no matter how many
embarrassing meetings I have to imagine
it's happening when I leave does it
matter I'm a doer and a freaking make it
happen er well I learned a lot from our
founders and one of the things I learned
was ask the impossible and really dream
big what you learn about people is if
you paint a very broad vision you
attract people who really want to make
it happen because there are dreamers too
so you can inspire people and with that
inspiration you get the smartest people
and they deal with a lot of stuff the
can an organization like Google which
espouses the idea that you're going to
give people in the organization fifteen
or twenty percent of their time to do
almost anything they want in terms of
innovation can that system work in
smaller companies can that system work
in any companies that leadership tenant
that can work across a broad range of
companies well in fact it worked at
Google when Google was tiny so the
answer is yes it does work in small
companies remember we give this to
engineers and engineers are not that
clever right if they're gonna work on
something in their 20% time
it's going to be something that's pretty
related to their training in their
knowledge and that's why it's so
powerful very very few people sort of
get off the reservation and do something
completely different from technology and
so forth and if they did we would
encourage it has something manifested
you can recall come from just that kind
of incubation virtually all of the
interesting apps now came from a
combination of an acquisition and a 20%
time if you look at maps if you look at
Google Earth if you look at chrome and
Android all of them came from somebody
trying something identifying something
and then we would say we have all these
20% timers but we need a real group and
the fastest way to do that was to create
a real group or a bio company what's the
most important change a most significant
change in your way of thinking about the
world over the last 20 years that the
impossible can happen I never thought
that the Soviet Union will improved so
easily and I never thought that the
Chinese would abandon the communist
system and that I had moved into the
free market so readily as was
unthinkable 20 years ago both has
happened the world has changed and it's
not clear exactly how it's all gonna
know it it is not exactly clear when it
will happen exactly but that it will
happen now in the long term 50 to 100
years yes and the center of gravity is
shifting to Asia must be because the
populations there that the talent pool
of 1.3 billion people are Japanese the
Koreans and the Vietnamese and the
others it can match Europe and America
but that talent pool was inert did not
have science and technology did not care
about science and technology
but now everything that you do issue is
doing
those records is a very important place
it was the most famous record store in
San Diego and one of the most famous in
the country when blink first started I
drove around about a 20 mile radius from
the store and I broke into every high
school at night and I made blink flyers
and I put them in every single locker at
all these high schools that we were
playing at the club downtown at that
point in time everyone in San Diego
wanted to support their local bands it
was just a really big scene so because I
put those flyers in those lockers we
ended up having on our first show out of
big club all the people came and we had
enough people that watched us that the
guy that owned the club invited us the
following week to play on the big stage
so what we did is not only filmed that
show we rushed and made a really quick
recording and it was our first recording
with a little Buddha statue wanted
people commonly refer to that record as
Buddha we made that to sell here in this
store so we would put five tapes in at a
time there's at the time where tapes are
selling and every week we would call up
and their other con where they go my
absolute put five more they're gone so
then we gave them ten they're gone
they're give him 20 next thing you know
we sold thousands of these tape
cassettes out of his records and then we
got our start on it was a you know
little suburban kids we had a dream to
be in the punk rock section and I'm here
now looking at all these things I grew
up on and if they're so insanely
important to me
vision I should be winning or anything
always always gentle winning the World
Cup but happened you
[Music]
[Applause]
still look back to 98 after the red card
I got against Argentina what went on in
my life and in my family's life after
that I think was very tough it was
probably the toughest moment in my
career
I was having deference I never felt safe
for three and a half years people used
to turn around and they're saying that
you've let your country down and you've
let your family down so how does that
feel I don't think I've ever felt as
alone as that as a person or as a
footballer you can knock a person down
so much that they just go under
outside pubs in London there was
effigies hung of me and this was on the
front of the newspaper it's just
something that sticks in my mind from
that time
oh shut about men
and then what
ten minus one student and boy still
emotional isn't it still wrong here
this is a saying that I usual the time
and it's true he's around world 98 was
just before the World Cup without was at
the top and then after I woke up I was
at the bomb and then you work yourself
back up the upside for me was the Greece
game
[Music]
once the game started was the staff an
incredible day for me
it was even going to the World Cup that
day or it was going into qualifying
games which none of us wanted to do
because the expectations of us I
remember
Teddy Sharon getting a free-kick on the
edge of the box and I remember putting
the ball down and I remember looking up
at the clock and thinking this is it you
know this is the only chance I'm gonna
get now the only thing I could hear was
the man and his drum around about here I
think and now step back to the deep
breaths run up as soon as it left my
father it was it
it was the lair this nothing I've ever
heard the fans it was such a huge moment
for everyone
I remember just running off and being
that excited just jumping up in the air
you know I could have touched the top of
a stadium if I wanted to because I felt
that higher
right the whole canvas is the idea of
the gulp there's the boy in the corner
my celebration and the words beliefs
trip and family what I needed and what I
had to get through off a 90
finishes it off being in front of the
blank piece of paper with experts around
you as well
I think that is much more daunting
stepping out in front of 90,000 people
playing football thank you guys so much
for watching and I hope you enjoyed the
video I'd love to know what did you
think what was a single biggest takeaway
that you took from this video that
you're going to apply to your life or to
your business somehow leave it down in
the comments below if you're within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes as well I also want to give
a quick shout out to Frank Hoffman Frank
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word and posting it
on Twitter
I really really appreciate the support
man and I hope you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much loved I'll see you soon